the jet engine powers modern life by
enabling fast reliable long distance
flight they can cost up to 30 million
dollars each
a take off a large engine will burn 60
gallons of fuel every minute
they can weigh more than ten thousand
pounds and produce more than a hundred
thousand pounds of thrust
which is probably why it's best that the
closest passengers get to these beasts
is looking at them from the cabin but in
a very ramoo Delta allowed us to stand
right next to one as it started up
no surprises it's loud and stinks of
burning jet fuel but the feeling of raw
power is awe-inspiring
engine tests are usually done behind
closed doors in 10-meter cells the like
bunkers we have an air inlet at one end
and a blast basket an inverted cone to
calm the exhaust before it's vented as
far as engine is concerned I guess it's
just hanging on the windows search for
James Insurance it's on weighing it's
it's doesn't know any different
we have our control room which is
essentially like your cockpit and it's
measuring everything that you would be
measuring on wing except for we go a
little bit further because we're testing
so we put in additional test probes and
pressure probes and we're able to see
that data that you're not able to see on
wing engines need testing after they've
been in for maintenance or rebuilding
which for Delta happens here at it's
tech ops facility in Atlanta technicians
and engineers can dismantle and rebuild
the many engine types that power the
Delta fleet mechanics repair or service
everything that needs it down to the
smallest part and then the whole process
runs in Reverse
each engine is in here for 50 to 80 days
before being tested bolted back onto the
plane and sent off the flight it's a big
operation with a simple goal of keeping
everyone up in the air